[Musique]
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont il se désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus cooney sq justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour chaque homme politique
personnelle est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
est dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 17 novembre
espace concours d'orbites la bataille de
l'espace à quoi joue poutine ce sont les
unes aujourd'hui de plusieurs grands
quotidiens français
bref la destruction d'un satellite par
les russes dans l'espace fait couler
beaucoup d'encre mais pas que le dossier
biélorusse le gaz l'ukraine tout est bon
pour pointer du doigt le kremlin et son
chef vladimir poutine on tentera en ce
début d'émission de démêler le vrai du
faux et de comprendre pourquoi la russie
fut cite aussi peu la sympathie des
journaux français
une pilule anti qu'ovide à la conquête
de l'amérique feather demande
d'autorisation en urgence aux états unis
pour son traitement anti qu'ovide une
pilule efficace selon le géant
pharmaceutique à 89% contre les
hospitalisations et décès si elle est
prise dans les trois jours suivant
l'apparition des symptômes
en france on s'intéresse aux traitements
développés par merck paris vient
d'ailleurs de commander 50 mille gélules
auprès du laboratoire américain mais
quel est son efficacité nous irons à
washington
que reste-t-il du mouvement des gilets
jaunes trois ans pile après sa naissance
samedi 17 novembre 2010 8 face à
l'augmentation des prix des carburants
des milliers de français décidé de faire
entendre leur colère aujourd'hui le
mouvement tente de trouver un nouveau
souffle dans une colère peut-être plus
silencieuse mais toujours présente donc
en pense défense et ce soir nous irons
justement la rencontre d'un militant de
la première heure maxi nicole place
ensuite au face à face avec la parole
donnée aux français emmanuel macron le
président des riches ou pas c'est la
question qu'on vous pose sur le compte
et des grappes d'ayrté france
[Musique]
tirs de missiles dans l'espace crise
migratoire ukraine la presse française
semble s'être donné le mot aujourd'hui
tirent à boulet rouge sur vladimir
poutine qui a la primeur de plusieurs
une le président russe est accusé de
multiplier les provocations et de
vouloir déstabiliser certaines régions
nadège abderrazak l'heure est grave
vladimir poutine mais l'europe en danger
titre le journal du dimanche
à quoi joue vladimir poutine demande le
parisien mais la une la plus surprenante
reste peut être celle de libération on y
voit le président russe lunettes 3d sur
le nez regard tourné vers l'espace
le tout chapeauté d'un titre que nous
qualifierons volontiers de culottée
trêve de plaisanterie force est de
constater que vladimir poutine n'a pas
les faveurs des médias meanstream
français et c'est un euphémisme
le patron du kremlin est accusé de
vouloir déstabiliser la terre entière
rien de moins et pas seulement l'espace
également où la russie a détruit lundi
l'un de ses vieux satellites en orbite
depuis
1982 un comportement dangereux et
irresponsable d'après washington pour
qui cela aurait menacé la sécurité des
spationautes à bord de la station
spatiale internationale
moscou n'a pas tardé à répliquer en
dénonçant des accusations immo creed de
la part des américains et voici ce
qu'écrit libération sur le sujet
l'espace est un gigantesque
de bataille un traité de 1967
ambitionnait de le démilitarisé loupe et
intimidations espionnage attaque directe
la liste ne relève pas de la science
fiction les dynamiques géopolitique sur
terre crée bel et bien des tensions au
delà de notre atmosphère et les enjeux
économiques envenime le tout en prouvant
qu'il peut cibler un satellite poutine
montre les muscles quand la france
développe sa stratégie spatiale de
défense la crise des missiles version
21e siècle ne se déroulera pas à cuba
mais dans le cosmos moscou accusé de
vouloir envahir l'ukraine et de jouer un
rôle majeur dans la crise migratoire à
la frontière polono biélorusse où des
milliers de personnes tentent au péril
de leur vie de gagner l'union européenne
pour la pologne c'est l'ombre de la
russie qui plane derrière le dirigeant
biélorusse alexandre loukachenko ne
serait en réalité que la marionnette de
vladimir poutine mais c'est vite oublier
la souveraineté de la biélorussie et le
caractère bouillant et imprévisible et
de son président qui a même été
désavouée un publiquement par moscou il
y a quelques jours après avoir menacé de
couper l'arrivée de gaz aux occidentaux
en cas de nouvelles sanctions il s'agit
d'une déclaration du président de la
biélorussie je tiens tout de même à
rappeler la déclaration du président
poutine selon laquelle la russie a
toujours rempli ses obligations
contractuelles et que cela plaise ou non
à qui que ce soit
la russie a toujours été est et restera
potentiellement un pays garants de la
sécurité énergétique du continent
européen il faut dire qu'on a connu
marionnettes plus obéissante mais cela
ne fait pas les affaires des médias
mainstream france est bien décidée à
faire du président russe le coupable
parfait vladimir poutine montre une fois
de plus sa capacité de nuisance on le
retrouve dans tous les mauvais coups du
moment massant cent mille soldats aux
frontières de l'ukraine tirant les
ficelles de la biélorussie dans la crise
des migrants la russie poursuit tous
azimuts sa quête de puissance le kremlin
veut étendre sa zone d'influencé
reconquérir le terrain perdu après
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
sur le continent européen
il mène une guerre hybride actionnant
des leviers militaire cybernétique
médiatique politique énergétique
migratoires cet activisme réveil de très
mauvais souvenirs les européens doivent
se serrer les coudes le rôle de méchant
l'art de la manipulation impose la loi
du plus fort c'est un sacré show lexical
qu'a choisi le parisien pourra décrire
un chef d'état en exercice
pas sûr que beaucoup d'autres aient pu
bénéficier dans les loges aussi fourni
est aussi soigné pour endosser le rôle
du méchant vladimir poutine est parfait
cet ancien du kgb n'a pas son pareil
dans l'art de la manipulation est
excellent à faire croire que la russie
moderne dont le pib n'atteint pas celui
de l'italie n'a rien perdu de l'empiré
soviétique qui régna jadis sur la moitié
de la planète
au nom de quoi il un poste chez lui et
ailleurs de la crimée naguère jusqu'à
l'espace aujourd'hui la loi du plus fort
le problème est qu'en face il n'y a
guère de monde capable de jouer les
gentils et de résister au-delà des
remontrances formelle les américains ont
le regard ailleurs sur cette chine qui
les inquiète tant les européens pourtant
les premiers concernés par ces foyers
attisés sur leur sol ont comme
d'habitude du retard à l'allumage une
objectivité qui laisse sans voix quoique
tout n'est peut-être pas faux parce que
c'est vrai chez l'oncle sam le nouveau
grand méchant en chef qui monopolise
toutes les attentions se situe plus à
l'est dans l' empire du milieu est qu en
europe en matière de retards à
l'allumage certains médias encore qu'on
sait dans la guerre froide font office
de champion et comme une ambiance de
guerre froide entre la france et la
russie alors que les deux pays sont au
coeur de bien des enjeux économiques
énergétiques et géopolitique en cette
année de campagne présidentielle
plusieurs candidats appellent à changer
de braquet à réchauffer les relations
entre paris et moscou qu'est ce que la
france pourrait y gagner c'est l'objet
de notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
jonas haddad porte-parole de xavier
bertrand qui est donc candidat
évidemment l'institut re à l'investiture
l'est républicain pour l'élection
présidentielle bonsoir jonas haddad et
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous avons
noté gilles rémy chef d'entreprise vous
êtes pdg du groupe siph allant vous
faites la passerelle régulièrement entre
paris et moscou puisque votre entreprise
est un acteur de référence dans
l'accompagnement commercial opérationnel
de groupes industriels français et
européens en russie bonsoir à tous les
deux et merci d'être avec nous alors on
l'a vu un cas de couverture ou à charge
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire contre
la russie de vladimir poutine rien que
pour aujourd'hui on sans compter le
journal du dimanche dimanche dernier ça
y est on est officiellement de retour
dans la guerre froide jonas haddad
d'abord vous me permettrez de vous dire
que bien sûr comme vous parfois je suis
étonné du traitement médiatique qui peut
être réservé au président poutine mais
vous savez est très souvent ce
traitement il a été par exemple aussi
réservé à donald trump ont considéré
comme étant le grand méchant loup est
pourtant lui n'est pas russe et donc on
voit bien qu'il ya une forme en tout cas
d'une certaine presse à chaque fois de
dénonciation permanente de ceux qui ont
envie de défendre leurs intérêts et
c'est bien ça le sujet vadimir poutine
défende ses intérêts c'est président de
son pays et on doit le lui reconnaître
et ont peut-être qu'on n'a pas levé
l'ipan des par rapport à ça nous notre
rôle de la france c'est d'être une
puissance d' équilibre c'est de ne pas
être si vous voulez en permanence à
vouloir tacler la russie essaie de ne
pas être non plus un vassal des états
unis mais d'en être un allié un allié
exigeant et on a vu ces derniers temps
que l'exigence c'est le moins qu'on peut
demander de la part de notre relation
avec les états unis ce qu'il faut c'est
faire en sorte de dépassionner cette
relation de jaillir part de là comme
dirait le philosophe par-delà bien et
mal pour voir quels sont les intérêts
français moi je suis porte parole d'un
candidat de quelqu'un qui veut être
candidat à la présidence de la
république française et l'objectif c'est
de savoir quels sont les intérêts
français les intérêts français c'est
d'arrêter de porte en permanence les
sanctions soient la russie c'est
sympathique de se faire plaisir mais en
permanence de vouloir sanctionner en
état avec lequel nous devrions pour
autant plutôt nouer des partenariats
de la même façon qu'on noue des
partenariats avec d'autres d'autres pays
ce serait la logique et c'est d'ailleurs
vous voyez qu'il ya énormément de gens
issus de tous les rangs politiques qui
sont rendus en hommage à colombey les
deux églises en hommage au général de
gaulle c'était la vision du général de
gaulle c'est d'être cette puissance
d'équilibré donc quand ces gens-là se
disent gaullistes ils ne sont pas
gaulliste à vision gaulliste c'est
d'être une puissance d' équilibre
c'était la vision de de gaulle c'était
la vision de chirac ça a été aussi la
vision de nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'ils
réussissent et à dialoguer de façon
franche et honnête avec vladimir poutine
c'est également la vision que nous
devons porter au sein de la droite
républicaine
mais attention c'est pas pour autant
qu'on ne peut pas critiquer certaines
positions de la russie voilà on va
poursuivre ce débat évidemment jonas
haddad alors il n'y a pas que la presse
française
ce soir le premier ministre britannique
a mis en garde moscou contre je cite
l'erreur tragique que constituerait tout
aventurisme militaire aux frontières du
crâne et et de pologne quand le parisien
lui se demande jusqu'où va-t-il aller en
parlant de venir poutine on est un petit
peu dans la même veine gilles rémy c'est
vrai un jonas haddad l'a 10 à 15
évidemment défend ses intérêts mais ce
qu'il est justifié devoir continu comme
un va-t-en-guerre la limite de
l'inconscience
oui je suis pas certain que tout le
monde défendre ses intérêts je suis pas
certain qu'une certaine politique
française défendre des intérêts de la
france et que la politique menée par
l'union européenne correspondent aux
intérêts des états qui la composent
aujourd'hui quel intérêt aurions nous
de
démultiplier une politique de sanctions
qui on le sait ne sert à rien les
sanctions ont notamment l'essence
européenne depuis 2004 sait on s'est
tiré une balle dans le pied on a on a
limité nos exportations a laissé la
place à l'autre aux autres et puis sur
un blanc beaucoup plus général est
beaucoup plus inquiétant en termes
stratégiques c'est que on pousse la
russie vers une civilisation qui n'est
pas la sienne et qui est celle de la
chine donc moi je te fais d'accord si on
prenait en compte nos propres intérêts
nationaux et je crois que c'est à partir
de ce moment là qu'on arrive à un
dialogue beaucoup plus constructif avec
avec la russie et puis en même temps
quand on prend compte comme premier
critère ses intérêts nationaux je pense
qu'on est plus à même de comprendre
l'intérêt de l'autre aussi parce que bon
là je vous parle je suis à moscou en ce
moment la situation et les vues d'une
manière un peu différente vous parliez
johnson mais ce sont les troupes
britanniques qui sont quasiment aux
frontières russes avec qui ont été
renforcées la la pologne puisque la la
la la la biélorussie et lundi dernier
encore en quelques genres tampon face à
l'ô tan les troupes françaises les
troupes américaines sont présentes dans
les pays baltes frontière même de la
russie l'ukraine qui est un pays en
faillite
ou là où la jeunesse fui le pays qui ne
respectent yves qui est qui and anna
d'intérêt évident à maintenir
l'attention pour pouvoir recevoir
défiant des financements et des armes
occidentales ukraine c'est la frontière
russe imaginons une présence recettes
est absurde que j'ai peut-être vous dire
mais imaginons une présence accrue des
chars russes à bruxelles ou à un ou à
genève ou à zurich donc il faut en
partant de cette prise en compte des
intérêts nationaux ni n'atterrit co nos
intérêts politiques nos intérêts
stratégiques
notre relation à l'histoire la russie et
une nuitée fait partie de notre
civilisation européenne eh bien je pense
que 1 ça nous permet de
progresser pour d'un doute que nous
propose intérêts et puis le mieux
comprendre loupe parce que je pense
qu'il ya une méconnaissance pas une
méconnaissance et ensuite ce débat
évidemment avec ses aspects gilles rémy
si vous le voulez bien jonas adan on en
parle évidemment de souhaite crise
migratoire la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne c'est ce qui
fâche évidemment en ce moment vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron se sont parlé
d'ailleurs lundi au vu de la situation
ils ont se sont convenus de faire une
désescalade de maintenir un contact je
cite contacts directs personnels il
était temps pourquoi cela n'a pas été
fait avant les prémices avait pourtant
été engagées à à brégançon il ya trois
ans déjà
c'est une excellente question qu'il
faudrait peut-être poser au porte parole
de la république en marche qui sont très
fragiles sur ces questions là en réalité
qui ne sont pas rapides qui ne sont pas
à gilles qui se disent européens mais
qui pourtant lorsque un sujet menace
l'intégrité européenne puisque quand
même lorsqu'on a un des pays qui est
membre de l'union européenne et qui
subit un véritable chantage migratoires
on n'a pas entendu monsieur macron se
positionner d'ailleurs c'est assez
incroyable regarder quand madame merkel
fait venir 20 millions de migrants on
dit que c'est formidable que c'est une
chance pour l'europe et que c'est notre
devoir d'accueillir du monde mais en
rouge immédiatement lorsque c'est la
pologne qui explique que c'est compliqué
on va dire que c'est de la faute de
vladimir poutine encore une fois c'est
pas notre sujet notre sujet c'est de
savoir comment l'intégrité du territoire
européen peut être respectés et si ça
avait été le cas et d'ailleurs bientôt
la france prendra la présidence de
l'union européenne il faudrait qu'on
sort beaucoup plus réactif quand on est
un partenaire on se dit les choses
honnêtement mais parce que on est en
capacité d'être partenaire je re donner
l'exemple de nico sarkozy parfois il ya
eu et on le sait des séquences très
difficile avec vladimir poutine mais on
s'est dit les choses en tant que tel et
aujourd'hui on ne se dit pas les choses
parfois on fait la leçon aux autres et
nous ne sommes pas respectée dans ce
concert des nations alors écoutez
pardonnez moi parce qu'on va revoir
poursuivre évidemment je vais vous
donner la parole à l'un ou à l'autre
c'est vrai que côté en tout cas de la
majorité il ya ce bouc émissaire est
tout trouvé je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'a dit par exemple député européen la
république en marche bernard guetta il
ya il ya une semaine
monsieur poutine ne veut pas de l'union
européenne et donc ils essayent de la
déstabiliser alors ça c'est important
d'écouter parce que c'est vrai que cette
accusation elle revient en permanence
déstabilisation de l'union européenne
gilles rémy est ce que c'est une
accusation un petit peu naïve comme le
disait jaune assad à tout à l'heure
chacun ne défend t-il pas ses intérêts
en géopolitique
il ya le grand méchant russe d'un côté
le gentil européens de l'autre c'est ça
oui mais en l'occurrence on parlait de
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de la
couverture quasi unanime de l'apic delà
de la presse française qui effectivement
tout à fait russophobie et là vous
donner la parole à bernard guetta qui
était un ancien journaliste que j'ai
croisés à moscou à l'époque soviétique
dans les années 80 qui maintenant est
devenu député la du mic en marche lui au
moins il est constant c'est à dire il a
toujours un problème avec l'union
soviétique la russie et que j'ai des
rares peut-être qu'il a lue par
badge en à penser ça mais effectivement
on a affaire
notamment l'occurrence un député qui a
qui manie les doubles standards quand il
était en acquiert lors de ce qu'il
appelait la plus belle des révolutions
et c'est à maidan effectivement on a
quelqu'un qui étaient étaient engagées
il est engagé cette tâche et champ droit
il a eu une constance et mais je pense
que je ne pense même pas qu'ils soient
représentés représentatif cheveux là de
la totalité de la république mais je
pense que c'est fini en l'occurrence une
individualité ya courant de jonas haddad
oui j'ai vu que vous vouliez vous vous
exprimez parce qu'on le rappelle vous
votre candidat vous vous l'avez
d'ailleurs déjà exprimé veut plutôt
tendre la main à la russie
général de gaulle que vous avez aussi
citer toutes à leur disais de paris à
vladivostok c'est comme ça peut-être
qu'on arrivera à mieux se comprendre
c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à mieux se
comprendre mais je voulais juste qu'on
peut était un mou par rapport à bernard
guetta ce monsieur lorsqu'il était en
france faut savoir qu'avant devenir
député en marche il était journaliste à
libération et c'était le premier à
demander à ce qu'on accueille sans
aucune condition tous les migrants dans
notre pays mais à partir du moment où
potentiellement un certain nombre
d'immigrés viennent ou pas du fait de
quelqu'un qui est proche de poutine
alors là on veut absolument plus de
migrants
si on suivait les qualificatifs de
monsieur keita lorsqu'il était à
libération on aurait pu le traité de
facho parce que tous ceux qui ne sont
pas d'accord avec eux sont des fachos
donc vous voyez comment il ya un deux
poids deux mesures lorsque c'est madame
merkel qui en capacité d'accueillir des
migrants ou wayne lorsque c'est nous la
france qui devrions accueillir tous les
migrants sans aucune condition
si on est opposé à ça on est des fachos
mais en revanche lorsque c'est
potentiellement des immigrés qui
viennent par le biais d'une autre voie à
bâle assez pour déstabiliser l'union
européenne donc on voit bien que ce en
même temps permanent cette inconstance
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est la
marque de fabrique de ce quinquennat et
moi honnêtement je ne suis pas là pour
faire du commentaire de la politique
russe je suis là pour me possible par
rapport à la politique française et en
voyant ça je pense que les gens
on a en un petit point de liaison en
tout cas on a compris l'idée date
effectivement gilles rémy par exemple
les états unis qui écoute les dirigeants
européens qui trahit son allié français
en l'occurrence mou dans dans cette
crise des sous marins australiens que
n'aurait-on pas dit si ça avait été la
russie comment justement sur place les
russes vivent t-il ce type voilà de
réaction de la part des français ce
qu'ils en ont conscience ont finalement
est peut-être qu'ils s'en fichent sont
simplement
c'est que
riou sera bientôt ils se moqueront un
petit peu de ce que pense la france et
les français l'europe et les européens
c'est ça ce serait pour nous les plus
graves parce que l'europe et la france
hélas ne font plus rêver c'était le cas
dans les années 90 comme l'union
soviétique sont écroulés ou ont là où
ils ont eu cette période de bain des
constructions comme on a un peu chez
certains
rapports et donc effectivement l'europe
apparaissait comme un commun zone de
prospérité et d' équilibre etc mais on
n'est plus dans cette situation là
aujourd'hui l'europe et vu ici comme une
des dernières régions quantité du monde
qui ne défend pas là qui ne peut pas
défendre ses frontières cas vrai
problème avec une immigration non
maîtrisée qui qu'il ne trouve pas son
sont une leçon d'unité qui n'a pas de
discours cohérent et donc et on revient
même temps avec des contradictions qui
deviennent de plus en plus insurmontable
en politique étrangère là là est ce que
la politique de l'europe et laisser
celle de la de la france et dans une
certaine mesure de l'espagne de l'est de
l'allemagne l'italie ou est ce qu'elle
est et les a posées par les pays baltes
pour des raisons qui sont les leurs ont
une relation particulière avec la russie
on a une
une pré frontières qui s'est créé au
sein de l'union entre l'ancienne europe
de l'est qui étaient dans le bloc
soviétique et l'europe occidentale les
gens ne pensent pas de la même manière
et mais en même temps ils n'ont pas non
plus la même relation que la russie la
hongrie qui est un régime on pourrait
qualifier de projet de la pologne a des
relations de nature complètement
différente avec la russie donc cesser
ces fragments d c'est compliqué et
surtout ça manque de visibilité et ça
manque de lisibilité pour les ruches qui
d'ailleurs - jamal l'union square avant
de refermer ce débat je voudrais vous
faire écouter une réaction à celle d'un
ancien diplomate français eugène berg à
l'auteur de la russie pour les nuls qui
est assez attristé justement de la
manière d'en tourner les choses écouter
faut la prendre telle qu'elle est
établir les meilleures relations
sur tous les plans on a fait des
sanctions après l'annexion ou le retour
de la crimée et puis ces sanctions
finalement ils ont coûté très cher à la
culture française
ce tri et que finalement on a obtenu peu
le résultat on ne change pas le
comportement d'un grand pays comme la
russie comme on ne change pas le
comportement des états unis de la chine
ou de la grande bretagne
donc vous voyez c'est relève un petit
peu du voeu pieux c'est facile de
critiquer poutine puisque on lui on lui
on lui attribue excusez moi l'expression
tous les péchés d'israël donc
il il est démoniser en quelque sorte on
voit la main de poutine partout voyez
lui-même il le dit avec sourire tiens il
s'est passé quelque chose dans un tel
pays or c'est moi qui est responsable
alors que pratiquement voit très bien
que il n'est pas présent partout où ils
peuvent pas tout contrôler et jonas
haddad un gène baptisé justement lui
ions à ces sanctions dont vous nous
parliez aussi vous tout à l'heure on
s'est tiré une balle dans le pied avec
cette politique de sanctions il est
temps que ça s'arrête c'est en tout cas
la position des républicains et de
xavier bertrand
il est temps qu'on a un dialogue qui
soit franc et voyez ce que ce que dit
votre autre intervenant juste avant on
ne change pas le comportement d'un grand
pays comme la russie mais en revanche
quine de ce que nu nous constatons c'est
qu'on en train de changer le
comportement d'un grand pays comme la
france la france n'est plus respectée
parce que la france ne respecte plus ses
alliances traditionnelles son rôle de
puissance d' équilibre la france est
aujourd'hui humilié par certains aspects
par la politique du président actuel oui
par exemple quand erdogan se permettrent
était le président de la république de
malade mental quand un certain nombre
d'autres pays se permette de tapoter sur
la cuisse de monsieur macron comme l'a
fait monsieur byden pour lui expliquer
que tu es bien gentil mon garçon mais au
final en réalité c'est nous qui décidons
ce rôle là nous nous sommes en train de
changer notre comportement et encore une
fois je veux pas être franco français
est autant cocorico mais si nous tenions
notre rang ce genre de discussions
seraient plus constructive et on
pourrait en conséquence décider
éventuellement de levée des sanctions
jamais le mot de la fin pour vous
évidemment tankers homme d'affaires
entre pas et moscou c'est ce que vous
souhaitez aussi aux pros beach est ce
parce que je suis dans le très appliqué
dans le commerce international et les
copains c'est qu'avec la russie mais
c'est l'intérêt de la france en général
de notre industrie et notre agriculture
ça me fait mal de sortir de passes et 2
par un magasin et de voir que tout les
franglaises fromage maintenant du
camembert au rang des imitations russe
et que les convois des petits drapeaux
suisses parce que là c'est la suisse
n'est pas concernée par ces contres
sanctions c'est douloureux je reviens
sur le le le nous avons nous une rupture
quand même dans la relation de confiance
qui s'étaient tissés pendant des
dizaines d'années n'oublions pas je
pense que dans la campagne électorale et
dans la relation de la russie on est en
guerre on y reviendra
c'est mistral ministre hans est un c'est
une
c'était une rupture delà de la parole de
la confiance et ça a des conséquences
qui se mesure encore où l'onu et
peut-être pas seulement réussi
d'ailleurs
dire que quand comme de les etats unis
sont remontées de cette manière avec
l'australie l'aurait-il fait avec un
pays qui a toujours respecté ses
contrats en matière d'armement aurait
fait de la même manière merci merci
beaucoup en tout cas tous les deux fils
rémi jonas à date d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france ce soir
et comme on l'évoquait l'instant à mon
secours et donc pointé du doigt par les
européens dans la crise migratoire entre
la pologne et la biélorussie pourtant le
kremlin réfute toute responsabilité dans
ces tensions sur le plan des
négociations minsk qui affirme avoir
obtenu l'organisation de négociations
avec bruxelles moscou salue d'ailleurs
ses contacts directs berlin évoque
plutôt une coopération pour l'aide
humanitaire alors que la situation est
de plus en plus préoccupantes sur place
pour les migrants des rades rien
maintenant
hier encore ils étaient des milliers à
masser à ce poste de frontière
confrontés au froid et à la fin les
migrants se sont aujourd'hui repliés
dans les forêts alentours de bruce guide
les installations sont de fortune et la
seule solidarité des réfugiés ne suffit
plus ce mercredi militaires pompiers et
bénévoles de la croix rouge ont mis en
place l'aide biélorusse leur mission
fournir les biens de première nécessité
dix jours après l'arrivée des migrants à
la frontière après plus d'une semaine
dans des conditions difficiles certains
ont même trouvé refuge dans un entrepôt
l'occasion de se reposer et envisager la
suite des événements
c'est bien mieux ici que dehors avec les
tentes dans la forêt c'est très
inconfortable
nous avions besoin de beaucoup de
vêtements chauds pour nous pour les
enfants mais ici c'est bien mieux
maintenant nous devons aller en
allemagne mais je ne sais pas comment
peut-être devons-nous repasser par notre
pays ou par la pologne je ne sais pas
l'allemagne une porte de sortie dans
l'imaginaire de ces migrants est un rêve
qui pourrait devenir réalité
à en croire les derniers échanges
téléphoniques entre angela merkel et
alexandre loukachenko le président de la
biélorussie et la chancelière allemande
ont convenu que l'ensemble du problème
devait être abordé au niveau de la
biélorussie et de lieu et que les
responsables désignés par les deux
parties devaient entamer immédiatement
des discussions en vue de résoudre les
problèmes existants
c'est dans ce contexte que sera étudié
le souhait des réfugiés de se rendre en
allemagne il y ait un échange de points
de vue sur la manière de résoudre la
situation et il est très important que
des contacts directs entre les
représentants de l'union européenne et
les dirigeants biélorusses étaient été
établi si la sortie de crise n'avait
jamais semblé aussi lointaine après les
affrontements entre police polonaise
migrants ce mercredi entre aide
humanitaire et réchauffement
diplomatique
les espoirs sont de nouveau permis la
russie médiatrice dans un autre conflit
celui entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
une trêve a été conclu hier entre les
deux pays sous l'égide de moscou un
accord trouvé après des combats
meurtriers prennent la région disputée
du haut karabagh les plus violents
affrontements depuis la fin de la guerre
l'an dernier la correspondance à moscou
de maylis destrait
le porte-parole du président russe a
commenté ce mercredi la reprise des
combats entre bakou et erevan ainsi que
le rôle de médiateur assumée par moscou
pour lui un sommet entre les trois états
sera nécessaire à un moment ou un autre
des processus de résolution du conflit
la reprise des hostilités à la frontière
est devenue hier une source de grave
préoccupation
mais grâce aux efforts de médiation de
la partie russe
il a été possible hier d'exhorter les
parties en conflit à faire preuve de
retenue
la russie continuera d'agir ainsi nous
espérons néanmoins que la seule façon de
stabiliser la situation et de mettre en
oeuvre les accords tripartites
nous pensons que tous les pays doivent
respecter leurs engagements en premier
lieu ce qui garantira que de tels
incidents ne se reproduiront pas
[Musique]
les combats qui ont éclaté hier entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie sont les plus
violents depuis la fin de la guerre 2020
haut karabagh à l'issue de laquelle
erevan avait cédé plusieurs régions à
bas coûts les affrontements d'hier
survenue après plusieurs semaines de
tensions ont entraîné la mort d'un
soldat arménien et de sept militaires
azerbaïdjanais et fait plusieurs blessés
dans les deux camps après l'éruption des
combats l'arménie a demandé à la russie
de l'aider à protéger son intégrité
territoriale conformément à un traité
d'amitié unissant les deux pays depuis
1997 erevan a finalement annoncé une
trêve après un entretien téléphonique
entre les ministres de la défense russe
azerbaïdjanais et arménien et on va plus
loin avec claude blanchemaison notre
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous l'arménie qui annonce
donc hier soir une trêve avec
l'azerbaïdjan avec la médiation de la
russie après une reprise des combats
pour autant c'est encore un cessez le
feu qui risque d'être fragile oui
malheureusement la trêve et est
évidemment fragile d'abord parce que les
arméniens dont jamais vraiment accepté
la trêve qui aurait été imposé le 9
novembre 2020 il ya un peu plus d'un an
la population
voulait que monsieur pas de xi'an
démissionne parce qu'il avait accepté
cette trêve il n'avait pas le choix
l'armée arménienne avait été vaincue et
dans le fond la trêve permettait de
limiter les dégâts en imposant un cessez
le feu y avait probablement pas d'autre
solution à l'époque mais un an plus tard
les arméniens continua à ne pas accepter
enfin la population n'acceptera d'autant
plus que les intérêts n'ont pas rendu
tous les prisonniers c'était une clause
de l'accord puisque la guerre était
finie il fallait rendre les prisonniers
de guerre ce qui est logique et elle et
l'azéri en en garder un certain nombre
peut-être pour peser sur d'autres
clauses de l'accord du 9 novembre de
l'année dernière alors du côté azéri
c'est pareil il ya des risques de de
rupture du cessez le feu les mêmes
causes produisant les mêmes effets les
azéri veulent arrondir prendre certaines
positions avant l'hiver et c'est pour
cela qu'ils ont sans doute attaqué il ya
deux jours des positions à des positions
arméniennes parce que pour eux
effectivement il faut prendre des
positions sur les hauteurs notamment
autour du du haut-karabakh avant delà de
la saison 2 de l'hiver donc des deux
côtés il ya des sources de deux de
mécontentement ou des objectifs qui
peuvent qui pourrait conduire à des
ruptures de la trêve mais moscou qui a
des rapports de bons rapports avec les
deux pays et probablement en mesure
d'imposer cette trêve bien que la force
de maintien de la paix russes ne
comporte que deux mille hommes ce qui
après tout n'est pas beaucoup ça veut
dire donc que un an jour pour jour après
la fin de ces sanglants combats les
tensions n'ont cessé de croire parce que
d'une certaine manière l'accord qui
avait été signé n'a pas été totalement
respecté
les nazis riz voudrait
consolider une frontière en dehors de la
partie cliquez et celle du nagorny
karabakh et
il est vrai que les arméniens considère
que les conditions ne sont pas réunies
notamment le retour des prisonniers pour
entrer dans cette négociation est
probable que monsieur pas de xi'an
politiquement ne pourrait pas entrer
dans cette négociation
il était un petit peu sur un siège
éjectable dans une position fragile et
s'il fait des concessions
aux voisins adversaires probablement que
la population ne lui pardonnerait pas
donc effectivement il y à des clauses
qui n'ont pas été respectées aussi du
point de vue des la verrie et notamment
le couloir qui devaient être construits
entre l'azerbaïdjan et le natif de
vannes qui est un parti de l'azerbaïdjan
qui se trouvent de l'autre côté de
l'arménie et une route de une voie de
chemin de fer devait être construite
effectivement je crois que l'azerbaïdjan
commence à s'impatienter alors c'est
vrai aussi que cet accord entre bakou et
erevan avait été jugée catastrophique a
notamment par deux par de nombreux
arméniens son souvenir de leur réaction
très en colère pour certains ils
réclamaient d'ailleurs depuis la
démission de leur premier ministre il y
a de cette frustration qui empêche
justement peut-être aussi la paix je
crois que les arméniens en effet été
très mécontents et le sont toujours y
compris d'ailleurs la diaspora
arménienne à l'étranger il ya des
arméniens dans beaucoup de pays du monde
y compris d'ailleurs en france et quand
on les interroge
effectivement il considère que cet
accord n'était pas équitable et puis des
négociations était prévue pour trouver
une solution politique qui est ces
négociations n'ont pas eu lieu parce que
l'azerbaïdjan considère qu'il est en
position de force et qu'il peut
peut-être reconquérir le haut-karabakh
complètement il a obtenu les territoires
qui sont autour du haut-karabakh que
l'arménie avait pris lors des conflits
entre 90 et 94 donc il a repris ceux ci
et ses territoires appartiennent du
point du droit international à
l'azerbaïdjan mais la question reste de
cette enclave arménienne en territoire
azerbaïdjanais et élégant ni karabakh le
haut karabakh pour lequel il n'y a
aucune aucune solution en vue vous avez
évoqué évidemment la médiation russe ans
qui semble fonctionner la turquie et
l'époque avait participé à la mise en
oeuvre du cessez le feu quelle est la
place et l'influencé de la turquie
aujourd'hui et je dirais dans la même
question comment se positionne également
les autres acteurs notamment l'union
européenne ce serait un petit peu plus
brutale sur la turquie la turquie a
participé à la guerre elle a participé à
la guerre aux côtés de la verve et jean
alors pas avec des troupes avec des
régiments ou des divisions mais en
prêtant à l'azerbaïdjan des officiers
d'état major qui ont participé à la
planification des conflits il ya un an
en vendant beaucoup de drones très
efficace dans la guerre il y a un an et
également du matériel électronique par
conséquent la turquie a pris parti elle
a pris partie de l'azerbaïdjan il ya
d'ailleurs des liens culturels
linguistiques aussi avec l'azerbaïdjan
et la turquie voit un grand avantage à
faire ce couloir dont je parlais tout à
l'heure au sud de l'arménie parce que ça
permettrait d'avoir un lien direct entre
la caspienne et la mer noire qui
passerait par effectivement la turquie
donc il ya un intérêt économique aussi
tout à fait important enjeu du point de
vue de la de la turquie et la turquie
aurait dû probablement prendre langue
essayé parlé avec l'arménie elle ne l'a
pas fait merci beaucoup au club
blanchemaison d'avoir été avec mon nous
avoir apporté votre éclairage
et dans la région toujours l'afghanistan
est au bord de l'effondrement économique
depuis plusieurs mois à la monnaie
locale perd sa valeur face au dollar les
commerces on se retrouve donc en grande
difficulté les monnaies étrangères sont
désormais interdites dans le pays de
quoi susciter l'inquiétude de la
population à maillas ou blé avec un
sandra shimbun
dans les banques et les marchés de
djalal abad les habitants s'empresse de
changer leurs monnaies et d'acheter
quelques provisions depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir des talibans les aides
internationales dont bénéficiait le pays
ont été gelés ce mardi la gagner a perdu
2% de sa valeur en une journée deux
semaines après l'interdiction officielle
de l'utilisation du dollar dans les
commerces
comme nous en portons la plupart des
choses de l'étranger et que nous payons
en dollars américains cela signifie que
lorsque la roupie afghane baisse tout
devient plus cher la raison de la baisse
de la valeur de la monnaie afghanes et
le manque d' aide internationale et les
problèmes politiques dans le pays
depuis l'arrivée des talibans au pouvoir
la monnaie afghane est la seule
autorisée à travers le pays les devises
étrangères sont désormais interdites
notamment le dollar pourtant essentiel à
la vie économique afghane utilisé pour
les échanges commerciaux et par les
banques un dollar vaudrait plus de 90
afghani aujourd'hui une situation qui
impacte directement les commerçants de
la ville
quand le dollar américain est élevée
cela affecte notre économie maintenant
nous sommes confrontés à ce genre de
problème parce que le dollar américain
est élevé et que la monnaie afghane est
en baisse il n'y a pas de clients
maintenant que tout est cher les gens ne
sont pas en mesure d'acheter quoi que ce
soit sur les marchés
face à la volonté des talibans 2d
dollarisée l'afghanistan et à une baisse
significative de la monnaie locale le
fmi dresse un tableau peu réjouissant
près d'un afghan sur deux pourrait
souffrir de la faim dans les prochains
mois alors que les caisses du pays se
vident à vue d'oeil et que les
fonctionnaires ne perçoivent qu'une
partie de leur salaire un d'effondrement
économique qui laisse planer la peur
d'une crise humanitaire sans précédent
retour en france à présent avec une
proposition de loi pour mieux protéger
les lanceurs d'alert l'assemblée
nationale vient de donner un premier feu
vert unanime à ce texte qui renforce
l'assistance à ces personnes et leurs
droits le projet de loi doit désormais
aller au sénat le texte veut corriger
les imperfections de la loi pionnière
dans ce domaine dit sa part 2 de 2016 au
final peu utilisé pour les lanceurs d
alerte une première victoire en france
alors que les étasuniens réclame
toujours l'extradition de julian assange
au royaume uni est fière des
parlementaires français se sont
mobilisés pour offrir l'asile politique
au fondateur de wikileaks
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec stéphanie gibeau lanceuse dallaire
bonsoir
rigaux merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france vous avez on s'en souvient
joué un rôle décisif en dénonçant les
pratiques d'évasion fiscale et de
blanchiment de fraude fiscale en bande
organisée de la banque ubs ont suivi
aussi de très près la sphère julian
assange que vous connaissez bien ce feu
vert des députés français ce soir pour
la proposition loi sur les lanceurs d
alerte c'est une petite victoire vous
êtes satisfaite ça va vraiment changer
les choses
est ce qu'on peut dire pour être positif
c'est qu'en fait des histoires comme la
mienne qui est dure depuis 15 ans
peut-être parler de dieu lune à songe à
l'instant et tant d'autres histoire qui
dure depuis plus d'une décennie
permettent justement à ce qu'aujourd'hui
il ya un cadre légal et qu'en gros ceux
qui vont arriver derrière nous soit un
petit peu mieux protégés que nous
maintenant attention parce que le focus
est mis sur le mécanisme de l' alerte
sur le mécanisme du lancement d' alerte
moi je n'ai pas entendu parler de la
correction des fraudes qui sont révélés
par exemple si je vous prends le dossier
des banques parce que je suis
directement concerné donc par ce dossier
ubs on a récemment eu les honneurs à
people on peut se demander donc à quoi
ont servi des alertes comme les miennes
puisque les corrections n'ont pas été
faites et la preuve c'est que des
dossiers comme les miens qui ne sont pas
gérées depuis 15 ans bah ça évite ce qui
est des lanceurs dallaire dans mes
banques on en avait un depuis depuis des
années il ya quand même un silence
absolu parce que les gens sont pétrifiés
on leur dit qu'effectivement tout
devient beaucoup plus transparent et en
fait c'est pareil alors au final
on va demander donc avec cette loin aux
citoyens de se comporter comme s'ils
étaient des autorités de contrôle et
c'est un petit peu moins ce qui me
sonne à l'esprit si vous voulez parce qu
en fait nous des gens comme moi ont été
punis de faire le travail de ceux qui
ont failli de ceux qui étaient là pour
contrôler et de ce qu'il était là pour
nous protéger donc il faut faire un
petit peu aussi attention parce que
j'aimerais bien mais je dois pas être la
seule à vouloir plutôt parler de la
correction des fraudes en même temps que
la protection des lanceurs d alerte et
que ce serait bien d'ailleurs par
rapport à ça qu'on entende des mots
comme la responsabilité comme l'éthique
et comme l'exemplarité alors il est
indispensable de protéger david contre
goliath a résumé sylvain wasserman le
rapporteur modem de cette proposition de
loi qu'est ce qu'il veut dire par là
c'est vraiment la réalité
des choses david contre goliath
c'est gentil qu'il puisse en parler
comme ça c'est selon l'expression que
j'ai quand je parle de tous les nas ont
donc j'aime bien qu'on prête mes
expressions ça veut dire qu'elle sert
vraiment à quelque chose et qu'elles
permettent d'alerter maintenant au delà
des mots comment se fait-il qu'il n'y
ait aucune action il n'y a absolument
aucun soutien et en faites ce que je dis
n'est pas tout à fait exact c'est à dire
que certains lanceurs d'alert sont
considérés comme des sur l'anc third
alerte et méritent l'attention des
médias l'attention des associations
l'attention des syndicats l'attention
des comités de soutien et que d'autres
ne mérite aucune attention c'est à dire
que tout ça c'est à géométrie variable
il faut quand même faire très très
attention à ce que ce soit pas encore
défilé qu'ils soient mis pour aller
attraper des petits poissons pendant
qu'on ne s'occupe un des gros poissons
et que c'est ça la france
bardon comment vous expliquer justement
qu'il ya certes un focus sur certaines
affaires et beaucoup moins sur d'autres
et bien c'est que certaines affaires
doivent être justement bien plus
dérangeante parce que là on va parler
d'un autre mot qui est le mot corruption
que l'on emploie absolument jamais vous
voyez là on entend par les lanceurs
d'alerté mais en a l'air sur quoi on
alerte sur des dysfonctionnements bien
évidemment en alerte sur des actions qui
sont illicites qui sont illégales en
alerte aussi sur de la corruption et de
la corruption sismique si la france a
refusé jusqu'à présent l'asile de julian
assange s'est bien effectivement que
tout ce qu'il a dénoncé sa pose un
véritable problème au plus haut niveau
donc moins je n'y crois pas à cette loi
de protection de lanceurs d'alert pour
tous tant que justement la france n'est
pas capable d'être
cohérente par rapport à ces actions
parce que qu'on nous parle de loin et je
vous dis c'est très très bien qu'il ya
un cadre légal puisque maintenant les
suivants vont pouvoir en bénéficier
mais encore faut-il que derrière les
lois soient appliquées que les fraudeurs
que les menteurs que les corrompus et
les corrupteurs soient pénalement
sanctionnée à très haut niveau
justement julian assange on le disait
les etats-unis qui réclament son
extradition au royaume uni les
parlementaires qui se sont mobilisés
pour lui offrir l'asile politique
est ce que vous y croyez vous pensez que
cela a des chances d'aboutir que julian
assange a des chances d'obtenir l'asile
en france
je pense si vous voulez que
jusqu'à présent tout le monde s'est
désintéressé de ce dossier
pour des raisons diverses et variées
je dois être la seule personne en france
ou de langue française qui est humain
livre préfacé par dieu lune assange
vous le savez puisque je t'ai déjà dit
sur cette antenne ou rt france est la
seule
télévision à m'inviter et à me donner la
parole depuis 2010 est j'ai été
complètement censure est boycotté par
tous pour avoir eu ce livre préfacé par
julian assange ça veut vraiment dire que
des instructions ont été données par qui
par quoi je ne suis pas dans les secrets
des dieux en revanche chez moi
aujourd'hui mais c'est important de lire
cette ce projet de loi il a été signé à
droite comme à gauche
qui a une forme de consensus aujourd'hui
et ben voilà les choses ont changé les
choses ont évolué absolument j'allais
dire merci de m'avoir interrompre les
c'est exactement ça c'est à dire que
l'espoir aujourd'hui hélas ce n'est pas
un combat de gauche ce n'est pas un
combat droite ce n'est pas un combat du
centre ce n'est pas un combat des
extrêmes quelconque c'est un combat de
chacun parce qu'on parle là la liberté
de la presse de la liberté d'expression
on parle du pays des droits de l'homme
alors est ce que c'est le pays des
droits de l'homme justement qui est
capable de montrer qu'elle est à la
hauteur de ses ambitions ou est ce que
c'est un pays des droits de l'homme à
géométrie variable
justement avec des supers lanceur d'
alerte et des sous lanceur d' alerte
donc il suffit d'être cohérent et moi je
pense que justement si la france veut
être cohérente avec cette loi de
lanceurs d alerte elle doit avant tout
montrer l'exemple surtout on prend la
direction de l'europe à partir du 1er et
du premier chantier monsieur macron
prend la direction de l'europe à partie
au 1er janvier donc en fait si on veut
montrer l'exemple il est bien évident
que c'est un problème justement de
droits de l'homme et c'est un problème
de
c'est un problème citoyens ça va bien au
delà injustement d'un problème que
politique politicienne comme on a bien
voulu nous faire croire jusqu'à présent
merci beaucoup à stéphanie gibbons
lanceuse d'alert un d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur ft france
la pandémie du commis 19 a fait
officiellement 5 millions de morts dans
le monde mais il pourrait être en
réalité trois fois plus élevé c'est ce
qu'affirme une dernière étude publiée
par le magazine britannique the
economist pour en finir avec cette
épidémie mondiale la pilule anti kobe
des très attendus notamment le géant
pharmaceutique pfizer a d'ailleurs
demandé hier l'autorisation en urgence
aux états unis pour son traitement une
pilule aux résultats prometteurs on en
parle tout de suite avec thomas bonnet
en direct de washington bonsoir format
est les essais cliniques de ce
traitement antiviral donne apparemment
beaucoup d'espoir pour la suite et en
prime il est plutôt facile à prendre
oui c'était un traitement proposé par
pfizer qui s'appelle le pacs l'eau vide
et qui est présenté par l'entreprise
comme un traitement très efficace
pfizer a publié ses résultats
intermédiaires et affiche le chiffre de
le nombre de 89 % d'efficacité pour
prévenir le risque d'hospitalisation ou
les décès pour les adultes à risque des
chiffres des données dont se félicite le
pdg de fêtes de pfizer évidemment
écouter
l'efficacité écrasante atteinte dans
notre étude clinique sur le pacs l'eau
vide et sa capacité à aider à sauver des
vies et maintenir les gens hors de
l'hôpital s'il est autorisé souligner le
rôle crucial que les thérapies
antivirales peuvent jouer dans la
bataille contre le coc vite 19
alors concrètement ce traitement de
faveur est un traitement qui doit être
pris rapidement après l'apparition des
premiers symptômes et c'est un
traitement relativement important
puisqu'il y à un total de 30 comprimés à
avaler dans une période de cinq jours
dont à 10 pilules de ritonavir qui est
un médicament qui est déjà utilisée
contre le virus du sida en tout cas la
maison blanche semble croire très
fortement ce traitement puisque selon
les informations du washington post 10
me on de traitement pourrait être
prochainement commandé par les autorités
américaines pour une somme totale de 5
milliards de dollars il faudra donc à
d'abord attendre l'approbation de
l'agencé américaine des médicaments
merci thomas bonnin non pardonnez-moi ya
encore une petite relance la mise sur le
marché prochaine avait des premières
pilules anti qu'ovide c'est aussi cette
bataille qui se prépare en coulisses
entre pfizer et msd
oui il ya la concurrence pour le géant
pfizer puisque merck propose une autre
traitement qu'ils appellent le menu pire
aviram traitement qui a déjà été
autorisé au royaume uni et dont la f10 l
agence américaine des médicaments doit
se prononcer d'ici le 30 novembre
prochain alors on sait que washington en
a déjà commandé 3,1 millions de ces
traitements proposés par merck il ya une
différence de prix entre les deux
puisque le traitement proposé par mer
qui coûte 700 $ par traitement et ses
500 dollars pour celui de pfizer alors
l'émergence de ces traitements
intervient au moment où il ya un certain
nombre de critiques notamment de la part
des ong qui travaillent en afrique sur
les profits engrangés par ses
laboratoires pharmaceutiques alors même
que le vaccin n'est pas accessible à
tous les habitants de tous les pays on
sait qu'il y avait eu évidemment des
discussions pour lever les brevets sur
la vaccination ce n'a finalement pas
abouti alors peut-être c'est une forme
de réponse on a appris que par exemple
preiser allait faciliter l'accès à ces
traitements pour les pays en
développement voici je peux vous dire
merci définitivement thomas bonnet en
direct de washington
emmanuel macron l'avait annoncé le mois
dernier 50 mille doses de maulnes upi
ravir le traitement anti qu'ovide par
voie orale développée par les
laboratoires américains merck justement
devrait arriver en france entre fin
novembre et début décembre déclarations
du ministre de la santé olivier véran de
quoi s'agit-il ce médicament fait ils
permettent de se passer de vaccins
éléments de réponse en images
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
et en attendant le nom de cat qu'ovide
continue d'augmenter en france plus de
vingt mille deux cent nouvelles
contaminations ont été recensés ces
dernières 24 heures d'après santé
publique france le taux d'incidence a
même dépassé la barre significative des
100 nouvelles contaminations pour cent
mille habitants l issue du conseil des
ministres aujourd'hui gabriela talent a
parlé d'une cinquième va déjà là la
cinquième vague est là dans notre pays
près de vingt mille nouveaux cas ont été
recensés hier c'est environ 60% de plus
que mardi dernier le taux d'incidence
est désormais supérieur à 100 sur
l'ensemble du territoire il est
notamment particulièrement élevé en
corse en provence alpes côte d'azur et
en région pays de la loire partout
l'épidémie accélère et le gyrus reprend
du terrain est resté avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
gilet jaune trois ans après sa naissance
que reste-t-il du mouvement dans qu'en
pensent les français ce soir nous irons
à la rencontre de maxi nicole figure du
mouvement et nous débattrons ensuite
emmanuel macron et il le président des
riches oui ou non rester avec
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes ce qui nous alertent nous c'est
la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui était accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
de son diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention on est dans un
système très curatif 1 c'est essentiel
d'avoir l'information pour pas subir
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
pickton est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont il désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique pendant la
rendant encore plus cooney sq justement
c'est une nouvelle forme de
communication assez verticale utiliser
des influenceurs pour ça comme politique
personnelle est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
est dans notre intérêt à tous
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de fine stratégie peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
[Musique]
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
les chômeurs et chaque semaine dans
l'échiquier mondial nous analyserons les
coups les plus complexes du jeu
politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter
ils étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni
sur la bbc une solide et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire que reste-t-il du mouvement des
filets jaunes trois ans pile après sa
naissance samedi 17 ans en 2018 face à
l'augmentation des prix des carburants
des milliers de français décidé de faire
entendre leur colère aujourd'hui le
mouvement tente de trouver un nouveau
souffle dans une colère plus silencieuse
mais toujours présente dans qu'en
pensent les français ce soir nous irons
justement la rencontre d'un militant de
la première heure maxi nicole place
ensuite au face à face avec la parole
donnée aux téléspectateurs est venu
elles mettront le président des riches
ou pas c'est la question qu'on vous a
apposé sur le conte télégramme verte et
france il est toujours le temps de
réagir
[Musique]
c'était donc le samedi 17 en novembre
2018 le mouvement des gilet jaune voyait
le jour en france mobilisation contre la
vie chère des milliers de personnes
investissent alors les ronds-points
excédée après une énième hausse des prix
du carburant un mouvement qui prend de
l'ampleur au fil des semaines et qui
attirent les caméras du monde entier le
résumé signée luc alléger
le 17 novembre 2010 8 partout en france
on pouvait croiser des gens vêtus du
gilet fluo obligatoire pour les
automobilistes sur les ronds points les
péages ou simplement il le laisser en
évidence sur le tableau de bord de leur
véhicule en guise de soutien à un
mouvement né sur les réseaux sociaux
motif de la grogne dénoncé la vie trop
chère et demandé plus de considération
de la part d'une classe politique et
médiatique centré sur la vie urbaine
parfois méprisante et déconnecté des
problèmes des français vivant dans les
zones périphériques annoncé en septembre
2018 l'augmentation de la fiscalité sur
le carburant a mis le feu aux poudres
sur le net d'illustrés inconnus se
démarque alors par l'immense audience de
leurs protestations on est traqué on
monte dans notre voiture de toute façon
on est considéré comme quelqu'un qui va
potentiellement payer mais qu'est ce que
vous faites du pognon des français après
l'acte 1 du mouvement un sondage révèle
que 77 % des français estiment que les
revendications des gilets jaunes sont
justifiées
le samedi suivant les champs-elysées
sont envahis par les manifestants
et des heurts violents avec les forces
de l'ordre se font constater dès lors
plus personne ne semble capable de
cerner ces français qui n'accepte ni
chef ni parti politique ni syndicats à
leur tête discret dans les premiers
temps emmanuel macron s'exprime le 27
novembre et dit comprendre la colère des
manifestants tout en condamnant ces
affrontements ce sera sa ligne pour tout
le reste de la crise mais le mouvement a
démarré et l'acte iii sera la journée de
mobilisation la plus violente du
mouvement à marseille une femme de 80
ans siné bray douane est touché par une
grenade de police alors qu'elle se
trouve à sa fenêtre et elle décédera à
l'hôpital le lendemain après la
dénonciation des taxes sur le carburant
que le gouvernement s'empresse de
suspendre pour six mois ce sont
désormais les violences policières qui
s'invite dans le débat public les
visages des blessés par les armes des
forces de l'ordre défilent sur les
réseaux sociaux il suscite des réactions
y compris à l'international nous
encourageons le gouvernement français à
poursuivre le dialogue et demandons
urgemment une enquête approfondie sur
tous les cas rapportés d'usagé excessif
de la force je voudrais rappeler à tout
le monde qu'en france nous sommes un
état de droit que quand il y à une
plainte elle est instruite et qu'il
faudra probablement expliqué à madame le
haut commissaire de l'onu l'ensemble des
faits et notamment l'extrême violence
qui s'est déchaînée sur les forces de
l'ordre pardon de le dire comme ça mais
on n'a pas attendu le haut commissaire
de l'onu pour faire toute la lumière sur
l'ensemble des faits dès lors qu'il y à
des plaintes et dès lors que nous
considérons qu'il faut évidemment faire
la lumière et faire toute la
transparence sur l'ensemble des faits
avec le temps le gilet jaune n'a jamais
été définitivement abandonnée des
manifestations le mouvement a eu des
hauts et des bas des morts et des
renaissances régulière et en ces temps
d'inflation et d'envol des prix du
carburant les gilet jaune pourrait de
nouveau s'inviter dans la campagne pour
les présidentielles trois ans après
l'acte 1 dont des gilets jaunes ont
donnons la parole un militant de la
première heure dans notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français nous allons à la
rencontre ce soir de maxime nicole cette
figure des gilet jaune qui vit
aujourd'hui en bretagne après avoir été
surexposés dans les médias ou plus fort
de la crise avec si nicole a donc décidé
de prendre un peu de recul peut-être
pour mieux revenir dans un futur combat
le reportage est signée sébastien dufour
avec katia technique
aujourd'hui je suis a dit non pour
rencontrer maxime nicole aussi appelé
fly ryder une figure des gilet jaune
bonjour maxime comment allez vous bah
écoutez très bien et vous c'est le
troisième anniversaire des gilet jaune
du début des rassemblements qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire trois ans plus tard
trois ans de luttes sociales où on a
tous partout sur le territoire a pris
beaucoup de du monde dans lequel on
vivait du pays dans lequel on vivait je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui a créé
des liens qui seront je l'espère
indestructible en tout cas comment il se
manifeste aujourd'hui alors qu'ils
amendent rassemblement alors la plupart
des rassemblements qui se sont faits
pendant la période de vide puisqu'il y
avait des confinement donc
l'impossibilité de se réunir dans la rue
se sont faits sur les réseaux sociaux
via des plateformes chiffres et parfois
pour diffuser des informations mais
aussi les gens faisait par exemple des
rassemblements dans des salles
communales et cetera pendant longtemps
d'un gilet jaune et à la fermeture de
celle-ci les gens se sont rejoints chez
eux donc elle est je dirais une
communauté qui s'est formée autour de la
volonté de changer les choses et de
s'instruire parce que c'est de
l'instruction civique quelque part à ce
qui ce qui se passe depuis trois ans
donc voila et puis après il ya eu des
confinement les gens commencent à
ressortir il ya eu cette histoire de
vaccination qui qui n'a pas à me trouver
un accord parmi la population ça va pas
mal divisés mais mais les gens ont cette
volonté de débattre mais si vous avez
vécu toutes sortes de pressions cours de
ces trois dernières années alors même de
la surveillance ou des pressions dont
vous avez parlé dans les médias comme
vous l'avez vécu
quand vous
vous retrouver du jour au lendemain avec
les policiers les gendarmes qui passent
sous les 12 jours chez vous quand vous
avez les renseignements territoriaux qui
viennent vous voir dès que vous arrivez
sur un lieu de manifestation quand vous
avez un premier ministre qui dépose un
article 40 contre vous quand vous avez
des amendes qui pleuvent
parce que vous êtes juste en train de
dire ce que vous pensez c'est un
quotidien qui est qui est
pas simple à gérer mais j'ai encore une
fois eu la chance dans ce mouvement
doivent rencontrer des gens qui qui vous
font sentir
entouré et qui aident à surmonter
certaines passadou vous poser beaucoup
de questions sur vos engagements sur les
risques que cela peut avoir qu'est ce
qui vous reste de ses trois ans maxime
maintenant vous avez pris un peu de
recul je dirais pas que ça m'a changé
mais presque parce que finalement avec
avec les rencontres que j'ai pu faire
les j'ai croisé des gens de tout le
territoire des gens de toutes les
classes sociales de de la personne qui
fait des ménages dans les ehpad jusqu'à
1 des banquets ou des chirurgiens c'est
une période de ma vie qui m'a permis de
comprendre un peu mieux qui j'étais le
monde dans lequel vivaient les valeurs
que je pouvais défendre ces trois ans de
discussions de débats de
de naïveté parfois d'erreurs aussi
qui peuvent coûter cher
par exemple ce que ce que j'ai vécu au
début quand vous êtes médiatisées où
vous attendez pas à ce que ça peut avoir
comme l'implication dans leur vie
personnelle professionnelle j'ai pu
avoir des phrases qui était pas
politiquement correct qui ont qui
pouvait être sortis de leur contexte ben
ma naïveté a fait que j'ai mal répondu
j'étais pas j'ai pas été très clair et
donc ça a pu causer des préjudices à des
personnes au début du mouvement après
trois ans de manifestations de
mobilisation vous en êtes tous
aujourd'hui j'annonce et je prendre un
peu de recul alors papa du recul dans le
militantisme à proprement parler parce
que j'ai des valeurs et s'endormir sur
ses valeurs ou se coucher sur ces
valeurs c'est quasiment impossible quand
quand on respire ces valeurs là mais je
pense que médiatiquement parlant en tout
cas cette fois ce besoin de prendre de
la distance au niveau médiatique c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment important
pour moi je pense qu'il ya besoin aussi
de se recentrer sur soi même et comme
envoyée à l'avenir alors maxime c'est le
prochaines années les gilet jaune
c'était le canari dans la mine dans le
sens où on n'était pas une solution on
était et on n'est pas une solution à
proprement parler on est là pour dire
que ça sent le gaz en ce moment ceux qui
nous dirigent ou ceux qui aimeraient
bien nous diriger plutôt que de se dire
va falloir trouver la fuite et faire
évacuer la mine et
eh bien il joue à craquer des aliments
direct ce que je retiens de ces trois
dernières années c'est que avant j'avais
aucune notion en géopolitique même si
aujourd'hui je suis pas un expert
j'avais pas je parlais pas de gestion de
crise politique de processus législatif
de constitution de tout ça c'était des
sujets
qui était soporifique rébarbatif ça
m'intéresse absolument pas et je pense
que ça c'est un des points positifs
c'est que si on veut pouvoir se dire
qu'on agit en tant que citoyens dans un
pays il faut il faut participer à tout
ça donc c'est hyper enrichissant et ça
ça permet aussi de savoir ce qu'on veut
plus est-ce qu'on veut pas que nos
villes deviennent donc on y travaille
c'est pas simple
et dans un contexte économique morose le
mouvement des gilet jaune pourrait-il
retrouver un nouveau souffle
huit français sur dix estiment en tout
cas que oui c'est la conclusion d'une
enquête ipsos sopra steria pour france
inter une écrasante majorité 63% pensent
que parmi les revendications des gilet
jaune la hausse du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages est toujours un enjeu
prioritaire pour les prochaines années
enfin trois sondés sur quatre pensent qu
emmanuel macron n'a pas répondu aux
attentes de ce mouvement alors trois ans
après les gilet jaune la flambée des
prix pourrait elle entraîner une flambée
sociale comment le pouvoir d'achat at il
évolué emmanuel macron le président des
riches ou pas on attend vos réactions
toujours sur le compte un télégramme
inde rt france et place au face à face
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
jacques myard maison maison maison mère
l air de maisons laffitte bon score
jacques avenir merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce soir sur ce plateau monique
d'abba porte parole de lutte ouvrière
bonsoir à vous monique d'abba et merci
d'être avec nous donc trois ans on a dix
jours pour jour après la première
mobilisation des gilet jaune qu'est ce
qui reste selon-vous monique d'abba de
ce mouvement avec un certain recul
aujourd'hui évidemment ce qui reste est
en tout cas ce qu on entend surtout
c'est c'est que ça a eu lieu c est que d
b des centaines de milliers de gens dont
on n'entendait pas parler avant et qui
qui se prenait pas qu'ils se mettaient
pas en avant parce que c'était des
pauvres c'était des gens qui avaient pas
les moyens de devenir à la télé de ce
rang tente de se faire voir et pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps ces
gens là il était capable de dire qu'ils
en avaient marre et de prendre là du
coup l'antenne et de se faire de faire
entendre vraiment jacques myard pour
vous c'est le seul héritage d'avoir
donné la parole à ces personnes est ce
qu'il y avait pour vous un véritable
impact de ce mouvement dans la société
française et un peu ethnique
l'abattre parce que moi je crois que
c'est pas du passé c'est quelque chose
qui est ancré aujourd'hui dans la
société qui marque les ruptures dans
notre société et la précarité d'un
certain nombre de concitoyens qui pour
moi n'est pas acceptable parce que
aujourd'hui le vote reportage était très
intéressant parce que cet homme disait
du fond du coeur ce qu'il ressentait à
savoir que il s'est battu sur le plan
social et qu' il n'a pas admis les
décisions technocratiques du pouvoir
d'en haut et je crois que c'est ce que
ça démontre parce que il y a eu de la
part du gouvernement dont on a dit qu'il
était le jupiter une méprise total sur
l'état du pays
or lorsqu'on prend des décisions il faut
regarder quel est l'état le social du
pays
c'était à social aujourd'hui
malheureusement n'a pas changé et cela
traduit bien sûr les fractions les
ruptures de la société française que qui
doit être qu'ils doivent être réparés
donc il faut pas quoi que ce mouvement
c'est du passé non ce mouvement
peut-être ne sera pas aussi ample que
nous l'avons constaté mais il traduit
une profonde rupture dans le lien social
de la nation qui sort qui est qu'ils
sont inquiétantes alors oui à lui
valence est parvenu à trouver
intéressant que salaires soutiennent le
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune et donc
effectivement nous nous l'avons soutenu
aussi même si si on pense qu'il aurait
pu aller plus loin et avoir beaucoup
plus d'impact sur sur la société si et
sur l'a2 de départ qui était celle de
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat s'il
avait pu gagner les entreprises et les
ouvriers les travailleurs dans les
grandes entreprises en particulier parce
que là où vraiment ce mouvement là pour
pour avoir de la force c'est ça sera par
les grèves massives et en s'en prenant
au profit du grand patronat là où il est
fait dans ces entreprises là est
effectivement s'il y avait pu avoir une
contamination de ce mouvement ce
mouvement là dans l'est dans les grandes
entreprises saurait changer complètement
la face et la profondeur de ce mouvement
jacques myard je vous donne la parole
dont oui dans quelle que soit voilà les
i et les i parce que je voulais vous
lire un terrain premier message
télégramme mais je vois que voulait
rebondir sur ce que nous dira moennig là
bas il s'agit pas de soutenir mais quand
on est au gouvernement il s'agit de
prendre en compte ce qui se passe dans
le pays et là où le gouvernement a fait
une faute capitale qui a provoqué tous
ces désordres c'est qu'il était aveugle
et qu'il était sourd et donc le goût il
s'agit parfois non papa fois mais
toujours pour un gouvernement de prendre
en compte ces revendications sociales et
d'essayer bien sûr d'y répondre parce
que lorsqu'on sait que dans notre pays
nous avons eu millions de peaux
permettez moi de rire que moi qui suis
de droite mais qui veut une droite
populaire et qui s'occupe des classes
précaires et des classes moyennes
ce n'est pas acceptable et je ne peux
pas me satisfaire
qu'il y ait dans notre pays 8 millions
de pauvres donc il faut mener une
politique une politique des revenus qui
permet à chacun de vivre par son travail
quand il en a et quand on est chômeur de
donner du travail qui est le lien social
par excellence donc modique là bas vous
n'avez pas le monopole je dirais de l'
approche sociale et de la proche
responsable dans le gouvernement
mais là où je vais peut-être vous
rejoindre et vous dansez étonné c'est
qu'il est tout à fait légitime que c'est
peu c'est cette révolte soit canalisée
et qu'elle ne puisse pas être une
jacquerie à ce qu' il faut construire et
pourquoi rires on est dans le même pays
on est dans la même barque et je suis de
ceux qui pensent qu effectivement le
vendeur et je pèse mes mots le veau d'or
a perverti parfois la vision d'un
certain nombre de gens qu'on est des
gens riches pourquoi pas mais il n'est
pas admissible qu'il y ait tant de gens
qui sont décédés sur le côté justement à
propos de richesse stéphanie qui nous
dit à deux euros le litre du carburant
il faut être riche pour faire un plein
pour aller bosser au smic alors c'était
justement la question que j'avais envie
de vous poser à tous les deux vous dites
ya beaucoup de colère dans le pays vous
dit le pouvoir d'achat et bien c'est pas
ça beaucoup de deux pauvres là la crise
est loin d'être terminée puisque le prix
à la pompe est au plus haut c'est ce qui
avait déclenché la colère il ya trois
ans et finalement c'est vrai on l'entend
à trop va voilà c'est pas parce que il
n'y a pas de manifestation dans les rues
mais c'est vrai qu'il n'y en a pas on
les entend plus est ces français en
colère comment vous vous l'expliqué
monique d'abba moi que j'en entends
c'est qu'ils peuvent plus faire le plein
d'essence qui vont travailler à pied
parce qu'ils peuvent plus remplir le
réservoir des gens qui sont vraiment en
colère de ça j'en entends et on a
d'autant plus de raisons d'être en
colère quand on voit quand même total
café 4,6 milliards de bénéfices rien
qu'au troisième trimestre c'est avec
d'un côté on a des gens qui ne s'en
sortent plus qu'ils peuvent plus payer
le chômage qui peuvent plus
mais maintenant ça va gagner les prix
aussi dans les supermarchés partout
l'inflation en mai mais sur l'inflation
d'un côté ils sont coincés ils
n'arrivent plus à payer leurs leur plein
d'essence et de l'autre côté envoie
total avec des milliards pareil et là le
gouvernement ou ou même les républicains
quand c'est qu'ils disent qu'il faut
prendre sur les milliards de totals pour
pur et dur cette inflation moi j'ai pas
entendu ça alors jacques myard oui alors
qu'il y ait des distributions de
dividendes à roues tranche ça pose le
problème effectivement je dirais de l'
équilibre dans la politique des revenus
des gens et des autres que les
actionnaires voudrais vous poser une
question parce que là on va partir dans
un débat qui est pas celui de base
justement je reviens à la même question
pardonnez-moi sur sur la flambée sociale
ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya pas de gens
dans la rue qui a pas de colère mais
tout de même on sent que c'est
relativement maîtrisé est-ce que tout de
même emmanuel à croire fait des gestes
notamment le bouclier tarifaire sur le
gaz et l'électricité le chèque carburant
le chômage partiel pendant le pot vide
dans le chômage partiel il est exact a
permis à certaines entreprises et à
certains salariés d'être payés très bien
c'est le quoi qu'il en coûte mais il
n'en demeure pas moins que il faut que
ce pays retrouve une politique des
revenus et que effectivement
on constate que ce soit dans la fonction
publique où que ce soit dans celle des
salariés qu'il y a eu des blocages de
salaire qui ne peut pas continuer donc
il faut que dans les entreprises d'une
manière générale on retrouve une
politique des revenus car le risque est
effectivement du ras-le-bol et je
comprends alors dans l'histoire de
l'augmentation du pétrole et de
l'essence à la pompe il y à des facteurs
internationaux qui je l'espère ne
dureront pas mais c'est certain que
aujourd'hui nous avons des concitoyens
qui souffrent qui n'arrivent pas ou qui
me le disait coluche la fin du mois
c'est au cash du mois et ça ce n'est pas
acceptable
or on a vu le gouvernement donner une
prime qu'il reprenait de l'autre par les
taxes on sait bien que ce prix de
l'essence ce sont les taxes qui font que
le prix est élevé et 6 lits à la marge
des pétroliers au regard de du pétrole
qu'ils achètent sur le marché
international est quand même très limité
donc c'est une question de taxation mais
là le gouvernement ne peut pas faire
baisser ses taxes par crainte par
crainte que ça puisse entraîner d'autres
facteurs par ailleurs mais je crains
fort que il est dans une impasse
sur wii sur les salaires c'est aucun
gouvernement n'imposera a aucune
entreprise d'augmenter les salaires les
augmentations de salaire et sont
indispensables sont nécessaires on s'en
sort plus les salaires qu'on touche dans
les entreprises mais ces augmentations
faudra les arracher au patronat ça va
aider des grèves ça va être des bagarres
durées longues parce qu'aucun
gouvernement c'est pas vrai ne donnera
l'imposera quoi que ce soit aux
entreprises parce que de toute façon les
entreprises elles font ce qu'elles
veulent c'est elle qui décide que comme
à cran leur donne des milliards qui
efface tout ce qu'elles veulent avec ça
c'est ce qu'elle demande et c'est ce
qu'ils attendent du gouvernement mais
jamais n accepterons d'augmenter en quoi
que ce soit leurs salaires s'ils se sont
pas les travailleurs qui par des grèves
massives leur arrache ses d'augmentation
alors écoutez moi une entreprise c'est
un destin commun ne l'oubliez jamais et
un dirigeant de l'entreprise
je suis désolé de dire il a aussi
intérêt à ce que son entreprise tourne
là vous vous êtes dans une vieille
notion de lutte des classes et c'est la
raison pour laquelle les français vous
suis pas parce que je crois profondément
qu'il peut y avoir dans chaque
entreprise une définition et une
progression
progressif des tca venir des salaires
pour permettre à l'outil qu'est
l'entreprise en soin de tourner neil je
crois que vous faites une erreur
fondamentale aujourd'hui ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il va pas y avoir des conflits
mais je crois que votre vision de lutte
ouvrière c'est à dire de lutte des
classes est largement par certains côtés
dépassé
pardonnez-moi monique d'abord on va
regarder un petit message qui vous fera
certainement plaisir trois sondés sur
quatre pense en tout cas qui manuel
macro on l'a dit tout à l'heure n'a pas
répondu aux attentes des gilet jaune
nous avons demandé donc cet avis aux
téléspectateurs emmanuel macron le
président des riches comme on l'a
souvent dit ou pas regardez cet avis
vient de macron et hors sol déconnecté
des réalités oui c'est le père noël des
riches suppression de l' isf du crédit
que du cic votre avis vous êtes
évidemment d'accord j'imagine avec we
will get chasser sur le père noël des
riches c'est sûr mais justement je
dirais pas qu'il est hors sol est
déconnecté des réalités parce que c'est
son boulot il est venu pour ça c'est
comme tous les autres présidents avant
lui on sait faut pas se raconter
d'histoires non plus mais il est là pour
ça il est là pour pour donner ces
milliards aux plus riches c'est c'est
pas parce que ils ignorent la situation
des pauvres gens etc même si il les
maîtrise les méprise complètement tout
le monde se rappelle de camp des petites
phrases de macron de quand il avait dit
que les gars étaient des lieux où ont
rencontré des gens qui réussissent et
des gens qui ne sont rien c'est pour mac
ronde toute une partie de la population
ce sont des gens qui ne sont rien ça
c'est pas moi qui l'inventé c'est lui
qui l'a 10 et ses phrases à lui c'est
donc effectivement c'est le président
des riches et même des très très riches
mais c'est c'est en toute connaissance
de cause c'est un choix volontaire
jacques myard portant l'insee nous dit
emmanuel macron oui il a augmenté le
pouvoir d'achat des français notamment
des plus modestes on m'écoute et c'est
l'épaisseur du trait que le gouvenement
dijon nama tu pourras l'achat compte
tenu des difficultés qu'on a eu dont
acte mais 1,6 sur 4 5 ans je dirais que
c'est l'épaisseur du trait et ce qui
n'est pas acceptable c'est effectivement
ça a été je lis très les commentaires
méprisants qu'il a eu pour les français
et ça pour moi ça ne passe pas parce que
ce sont des hommes des femmes qui
travaillent et qu'ils doivent avoir la
dignité justement de personnes qui
travaillent et aujourd'hui quand
gouvernement claironne qu'il a eue 1,6
pour cent d'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat je peux vous dire que même dans
les classes moyennes quand on dit ça ils
sont plus qu'étonné et vous montre la
feuille d'impôts donc ça mérite quand
même qu'on y réfléchisse deuxièmement
c'est très bien qu'il ya eu une deuxième
note une deuxième étude qui a montré que
malheureusement les plus précaires les
personnes les plus faibles avait une
perte de pouvoir d'achat donc on s'amuse
pas à faire cela parce que ça sacré
justement je dirais le risque de haine
et le risque de la révolte ont peut-être
qu'on a réussi à maintenir pour 90 % 95
% des français
le pouvoir d'achat mais on n'a pas à
véritablement
le claironner car ces appels l'épaisseur
du trait alors une voix dissonante ce
soir dans la majorité il faut bien le
dire de nos messages télégramme celle de
michel j'ai beaucoup voyagé je suis bien
heureux d'être en france faut arrêter de
se plaindre on a quand même les aides la
sécu le chômage partiel les allocs en
pleine crise sanitaire qu'est ce que
vous répondez à michel monique da ba ba
évidemment en vivant en france on n'a
pas les mêmes conditions que ceux qui
vivent au liban en afghanistan où je ne
sais où
c'est ok mais mai et alors c'est on est
dans un pays où le la le cac 40 la
bourse a battu son record historique la
semaine dernière donc l'argent il y en a
plein le cac40 ses 60 milliards de
bénéfices pour les six premiers mois de
l'année c'est ça c'est cet argent il y
en a plein c'est au contraire alors
qu'on pourrait avoir bien plus dans les
services publics ça fait des années que
l'état se désengage des services publics
en vingt ans il ya eu 100 mille lits
supprimés dans les hôpitaux c'est on va
dire youpi c'est bien tout ce qui se
passe ici parce que ça peut être pire
ailleurs ben non pourquoi voir là où
c'est pire ça pourrait être mieux ça
pourrait être mieux et en prenant sur
les profits qui sont qui sont colossaux
et qui sont faits dans ce pays là il ya
aucune raison pour que les salariés
soient à chaque fois les ce qui est
qu'ils doivent payer ceux qui doivent
pas parce que maintenir le pouvoir
d'achat le chômage partiel ça quand même
amputé les salaires de 100 200 300 400
euros quelquefois c'est là les
travailleurs il a fallu qu'ils
continuent à vivre avec ça et ça c'était
une vraie baisse des
salaires et des revenus ça a été et
c'est pas fini parce que l'ennemi la ccc
les plus pauvres pour macro et dans les
plus pauvres voyaient les chômeurs etc
aux chômeurs qui veut s'attaquer
maintenant y compris en suspendant et en
supprimant les allocations s'il n'y a
pas des recherches
massives d'emplois etc donc oui le sait
le président des riches est l'ennemi des
pauvres merci en tout cas monique débat
merci également à chaque milliard
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir et c'est
la fin de cette émission un rendez vous
demain à 20 heures d'ici là n'oubliez
pas de réagir sur notre un télégramme et
l'actualité continue ce faire ces france
[Musique]
nouvelle hausse de 12 6% pour les prix
du gaz au 1er octobre du côté des
carburants ce n'est pas mieux qu'à part
redonner un peu de marge pour pouvoir
d'achat l'exécutif est complètement
impuissant non les tailles vous fait pas
cadeau l'état c'est nous donc on se fait
des cadeaux à nous mêmes le problème
c'est que ça ne résout pas le problème
c'est le décale il faut qu'il fasse
quelque chose de visible et baisser une
taxe n'est pas visible en revanche vous
envoyez un chèque séville c'est pas
quand les matières premières explosent à
la hausse qu'il faut se poser la
question c'est avant tout gouverner
c'est prévoir mais c'est pas seulement
prévoir sa réélection
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
les gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose alors jean francky